hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the amnesia
custom story the gray eagle so I don't
really know much about this but I know
that it's pretty good it's highly rated
and that's not often seen around here
and am knees got some story so as we're
waiting for amnesia machine for pigs to
roll out I want to keep heading these
good ones while I still can
so by fatalist James 30 30th year
physicist from New York today he's got a
long-awaited letter and preparing for
his first trip across the ocean wouldn't
it be his last trip in life what kind of
question is that would it I don't know
why you asking me how do you know what
are you saying is that supposed to be
ominous I don't okay six of July 1886
Atlantic Ocean oh wow we're actually on
the ocean well done you actually tried
to make a boat nice I like it so this is
obviously highly reviewed it's not a
full conversion mod but I never hold
that against anything dear James Abrams
JJ Abrams we are interested in your work
in the field of low-temperature physics
and invite you to the annual scientific
conference in London beginning childen
June 14th 9:00 a.m. okay London Royal
Society gamma lantern cuz shits about to
go down and I know it
when is [ __ ] not about to go down in an
amnesia custom story I would like to
know I sincerely would love to know I've
worked on on this there is a little ship
II will okie-dokie it looks at almost
authentic okay yeah I see it
rabble rabble rabble rabble rabble
rabble rabble I'll come join the rabble
Jimmy can I join the rabble this way why
can't I join the rabble hi wandering the
damned rabble well alright screw you
rabble I don't even want to deal with
you anymore
I'm going to sleep
apparently I am going to sleep well I
like to sleep with my head on the edge
of the wood of the bed frame more
comfortable that way
say whoa where am i I assumed to have
been transported somewhere else hmm
interesting
you're not my darling where's my baby
strange things are happening all right I
am awake again and it is now raining on
the high seas Oh can I go oh turbulence
Oh bad turbulence are we about to start
flooding ow owie my back
what happened did we hit an iceberg ha
ha and that's all there is to it okay
we're pretty much dead everyone died
except for me huh well we're gonna find
out why asking me again with the
questions
ha okay yeah this is normal I like the
sound of this and look and feel and
touch and taste is good yeah
hello walking through the woods alone a
note here do not look for the key I
buried it along with the body but if you
still want to get it buried head behind
the shack is just the place okay
strange hello is someone there
that sounded like a say what was that I
didn't even said what was that okay all
right this is good
I like this large oil potion okay
something about buried behind the Shack
is this a shack I can't even get behind
it can't even get in it
can't get a loo the hell was that
what the hell is going on here nothing
makes a sense you save me to be on an
island but I can't get in this house
okay this must not be the Shack I've got
to find another place yeah there again
with the dead bodies and whatnot is this
where the dead body is can I dig here
what's with this is weird what is this
what is going on here everybody tell me
what's going on is strange
can I jump off and drown myself oh hi
well someone's warded this guy okay I
something tells me I don't want to go in
the catacombs alright okay
so it's not much place to walk around
here but I'm trying to find something or
anything
is this a lot of invisible walls
blocking me from going to different
places so I'm assuming that the shack
has gotta be around here somewhere if
that abandoned oh hello
this must be it okay this looks nice
hello alright
oh there it is Hey Agrippa oh I work
fast or that was weird
I'm gonna go if that was weird okay it
must be for this house well what is
going on okay it's just I'm totally not
used to anything like this cuz customs
Tories are usually not like that at all
it's a feather on the ground in there
why that music dude a nice painting why
it's actually bright in here I don't
need this okay this is normal okay
you're trying to keep something down
there but why why open damn you are you
locked your lock door - okay I guess I'm
allowed down and um this and that's it
there it's here tinderbox rabbit put the
rabbit in the fire
this rabbits on fire okay is there
anything else in here that I would need
aha key I see you give me that chair
give me a chair give me that chair
dammit this charile have to do up okay
excuse me
okay oh hi dead body where'd you come
from
can I hide in here am I supposed to hide
am i hiding now is that the deal okay
the key to the cellar all right good I
didn't want to go in the room I want to
go in the cellar yeah that's what I
wanted this is so weird
I've never been just drop okay
I didn't close the cellar door probably
a bad thing
okay Labbit aureum okay laboratorium
yeah look at arm am I supposed to take
this and sacrifice it somewhere else you
still alive
you're breathing slap slap slap wake up
wake up I need your help okay that's
nothing hello hello stuff it in there
okay screw the arm
I need a knob thingy for that never gets
jump sometimes the sphere and may not
work the first time yeah
oh crap oh crap oh yeah goodies go the
other way how do i lubricate it that's
what she said okay he's gone we're okay
but seriously what am I supposed to do
here hi buddy you go do your thing I'm
gonna do something else now as well as a
slice this guy's head off with that saw
it's weird that the first instinct that
I go to is how am I supposed to kill
this guy
how quickly can I kill him which is the
most effective way to destroy this guy
yeah yeah I know immoral oh yeah I feel
real bad about it but let me you know
how do I kill him okay so I guess I
follow this guy into the darkness
looking for what I have no idea
find a crowbar and the new Danny I
cannot open the shack door can you work
it out how about with the crowbar we
look fingers tasty delicious fingers for
everybody wasn't it all right I won't
bother you while you're enjoying your
meal
excuse me they just try something I
don't think I'm supposed to use the
crowbar and this stuck lever here but no
okay I need to go outside to the shack
love shack not a Love Shack with these
monsters I hope but you know I love
shack nonetheless give me thank you back
out to the forest of haunted nightmares
I was just going to a science constant
conference what the hell happened a
science concert maybe good thing I am so
strong I broke oh good a drill
Oh bad a drill no one will find to be in
my Shack hello is anyone out there okay
I think I'm okay
where where where where where why why
why the pooper ah it was a pooper okay
that's how it's go that's how it's gonna
be
yeah I was seriously thinking about it I
haven't played a custom story where they
threw moose man at me in a long time
like it's been forever why is this green
now blue whatever you want to go chanson
changed try this yeah
Oh Boyle rule
thoughtful rules we're making good time
I guess if we wanted to go in the
catacombs I suppose I would just at this
point I would take that piece of wood
and just swim and just keep going until
hopefully I either die or get rescued
okay so that's locked well what am I
supposed to do about that hammer oh okay
well it's not locked it was just stupid
I was standing on it or something
all right down into hell we go
why okay sorry sorry I scared you hope I
scared you I like I like oh okay so what
are we doing here
cannon what the hell where'd you come
from
I thought there wasn't any new stuff in
this but apparently there might be cuz I
don't remember
to the canid chunin fire
oh it's so fire that cannon in a
heartbeat something was charging down
this door I think that's what they did
down here they like sent people down
this Owen just fired a freaking cannon
Adam all right know that you know that
yo bar the cannon Burt Burt bud shirt
okay I'm not going down there
ever oh god damn it
that was me that was me okay I'm an
idiot why did that scare me I have no
idea I just saw a big shadowy figure I
saw a shadow I died that was B I'm let's
all ignore that left let's everyone
forget that that happened like forever
no one ever mentioned that ever again
I got scared by a bird statue that is a
new low a new low for markiplier oh no
one should know about what happened at
the station yeah you need to block the
main entrance to the drainage system
this is the only way through which you
can get to the station on the other
passages I have already taken care of
that's it get out of here quickly as
possible but I do not advise you go the
service a curse it's sect again got out
of their nasty holes and scurry through
the neighborhood and you know what
happens to those who fall into their
clutches you can follow us to the
Eastern tunnel okay all right good good
for that let me create a hiding it's
just in case I need it
I am such a [ __ ] I just I'm so dumb
okay what do I got here anything that I
can actually oh great I just ran out of
oil because I've literally been standing
around with my lantern on no wonder I
ran out of oil and a friggin idiot I am
so dumb they're like a torch on the wall
please that ominous glow is very okay
I'll go in there alright I'll go this
way
oh man I've got like no good choices to
go anywhere I'm just gonna hunker down
by this bird and cower until it's over
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]
no don't